[Musik]
es ist urlaubszeit und die promis lassen
sich gut gehen
viele sind am feiern und das wäre vor
einigen monaten noch gar nicht denkbar
gewesen
model carina hat ihren sommerurlaub auf
mykonos verbracht obwohl an
griechenlands badestränden strenge
regeln gelten und nur 40 personen auf
1000 quadratmetern erlaubt sind teilte
carina neben pool und strand fotos auch
jede menge partyspaß auf instagram
[Musik]
die freundin von scooter frontmann hp
baxxter lisa keller genießt partynächte
auf sand tropez am hafen feiert sie mit
wunderkerzen und dutzenden leute
[Musik]
model bonnie strange genießt ihr leben
in vollen zügen auf instagram zeigt sich
die moderatorin die inzwischen auf ibiza
lebt nackt im pool aber auch beim feiern
liebt sie es feucht-fröhlich und trinkt
ausgelassen mit ihren freunden
[Musik]